all right hello caller location you have
an energy of like this edgy cool badass
kind of guy and you're in DUMBO let's
talk about that sure go for it what made
you want to take on this film and it's
so cool seeing your sensitive side and
what maybe want to take on this film
well thank you for the character
breakdown I should get that out of the
way and just that when I heard the three
words Tim Burton Dumbo I just it was a
no-brainer for me I really want to be
parts what I sent Tim an email about how
I felt about the story I had read the
script and why I would love to be part
within this out with Tim and that was
this yeah it offers up the opportunity I
think this world and the the canvass of
circus life and the isolation of the
central character Dumbo the enforced
isolation that offers up a lot of the
themes that Tim has in various different
stories explored and albeit in a new in
the new dynamic and and knowing how much
the life of the circus how chaotic it
could be and how colorful it could be
and how the circus basically is the
representation of a bunch of outsiders
who don't fit in in societal norms I
knew the Tim would bring enormous life
to it so it was a dream to do this and
also to do something I kids can see yeah
there's not many of my films because of
those wonderful character virtues you
mentioned initially that my films can
see you know a lot of the stuff that
I've explored however I'm in real life
heard kind of darker and bit more
violent emotionally psychologically
whatever this while there is darkness in
it there is greed there is cruelty all
those things this film is constantly
striving to inhabit the light and to
inhabit a place of kindness and
inclusion and like I stuff yeah what was
it like on set it's cool it's fun yeah
yeah it really was was fun it was easy I
mean he creates a kind of a familial
atmosphere on the set and obviously
Danny Michael and Ava had worked with
him a number of times each before so I'm
sure there was a familiarity there that
bled into everyone's experience also
some of the crew the cameraman and the
the costume designer Colleen that would
he'd worked with a number of time so it
was very much like a family very much
like you know a modern-day static circus
yeah
did did your kids get to come on set and
if not are they going to be at the
premiere yeah there was a unset business
and yet I get pretty bored by my stuff
there's no you know except for a day
like today one of my lads with me and
he's unveiling of the Dumbo cupcakes he
was kind enough to bring me one it was
good yeah it was good okay I'll have a
nibble
yeah and premiere don't know yes yeah
don't oh yeah that'll be cool
yeah something yeah you know to show to
the many I mean I'm not assuming for a
second that they're gonna like it
no big dangerous territories answer for
me my two thumbs down and that's okay I
can just do it just for the fun of it oh
yeah you did you cried I bawled
oh really Shan when fantastic four times
oh yes you're welcome
it was really good also you're not on
social media no why what I want to like
and comment some Collin quotes and
pictures yeah no reason I I just don't
feel there I have no desire to be hmm at
all
I just yeah there's no decision not to
be yeah the decision is not to be it's
it's there's no decision well that thank
you
yeah well thank you so much Collins
where you taught me you to invest
you